alors je vais vous proposer un petit
voyage dans le futur
imaginons que nous sommes en 2070 et
imaginons que mes étudiants en
énergétique me pose la question mais
expliquez nous comment la suisse est
devenue indépendante et neutre vous ce
faire j'ai dit mais je vais d'abord vous
expliquer l'énergie à l'énergie la
première chose qui est importante c'est
de comprendre qu'on a besoin d'énergie
pour vivre chaque personne pour faire
fonctionner son corps a besoin de
l'équivalent de 25 centilitres d'essence
donc ça c'est l'énergie qu'on a besoin
pour faire fonctionner notre corps en
même temps on a besoin de se loger de se
déplacer de produire et la quantité
d'énergie qui est nécessaire pour faire
ces trois activités c'est l'équivalent
de 5 5 litres d'essence on peut dire dès
lors que l'énergie est vraiment le
moteur de notre société
est ce qu'on a vraiment un problème
d'énergie je peux vous répondre non
parce que le soleil nous apporte en une
heure et demie toute l'énergie dont on a
besoin pour vivre un nom autrement dit
si on était capable de capturer toute
l'énergie que l'on reçoit du soleil sur
une année on pourrait vivre sans le
modifier quoi que ce soit six mille cinq
cents ans
alors vous allez me dire oui mais le
soleil y brille pas tout le temps est
effectivement c'était ça le problème
c'est ça le problème pour nous et
c'était également le problème pour la
nature et la nature elle a trouvé une
solution pour résoudre ce problème là le
soleil étant intermittents ne brillant
pas la même chose en était en hiver et
bien elle a mis en oeuvre un procédé
chimique un procédé en réalité
biochimiques qui prend du ce des
éléments qui se trouvent dans
l'atmosphère du co2 de l'eau et qui
grincent à l'énergie solaire va réaliser
un stockage de l'énergie
c'est ce qu'on appelle la photosynthèse
et la photosynthèse va produire
dubois va produire aussi tout ce qu'on
connaît comme étant la nourriture le blé
les carottes etc
l'opération de la photosynthèse est un
stockage d'énergie qui nous permet nous
en tant qu'être vivant de brûler ce
qu'on connaît bien on va brûler des
calories 1
en fait vous mangez vous prenez de
l'énergie et grâce à l'oxygène qui se
trouvent dans dans l'environnement vous
allez obtenir toute l'énergie dont vous
avez besoin pour vivre
alors si vous voyez voir ici c'est aussi
un cercle qui est super intéressant
c'est que le co2 qui a été capturé par
la nature est finalement rendu à la
nature et on a un cercle qui fonctionne
très bien
la nature il ya 100 millions d'années a
décidé de prendre une toute petite
partie de cette biomasse pour et là
enfoui dans le sol dans les couches
géologiques profondes et ce faisant elle
a concentré la quantité d'énergie on a
eu une énergie qui étaient stockés c'est
le pétrole et l'homme a découvert le
pétrole il a extrait il a transporté il
a procès s'est transformée distribués
pour finalement produire les besoins de
logements pour le logement pour le
confort pour le transport pour la
mobilité et pour la production
malheureusement en ce faisant on a remis
dans l'atmosphère du co2 qui avait été
capturé il ya 100 millions d'années
hélas quand sur une concentration du co2
a augmenté
le fait que ça la concentration de
monter c'est exactement comme si on
avait acheté une écharpe et le fait
qu'on ait une écharpe fait qu'on a plus
chaud et on expérimente aujourd'hui le
réchauffement climatique alors c'est
peut-être important de se dire
regardons un petit peu ou comparant les
ordres de grandeur une chose qui était
intéressante c'est que l'homme pour
vivre produit 2 kg de déchets vous savez
combien l'homme produit avec les 5
litres qu'il consomme par jour 14 kilos
alors imaginez que vous deviez tous les
jours prendre 14 kilos depuis votre
appartement est le maître
sur le trottoir par chance ou par
malchance le co2 n'est pas un déchet
solide c'est un déchets gazeux
il est parti dans l'atmosphère il sert
juste à augmenter la température du
monde
l'augmentation de la température a
souvent été traité un petit peu avec
humour on a ce ce tour ce blanc qui est
perdue sur son iceberg
ou bien même les encaveurs valaisan qui
commence à rigoler en voyant arriver sur
le marché des vins anglais ça c'était
avant parce que maintenant on est
confronté à d'autres signaux d'alert qui
sont bien plus dérangeant on entend
parler d'inondations d'en parler de
sécheresse d' incendies de vagues de
chaleur tout ça est dû au réchauffement
climatique et on le sait très bien
les dirigeants de tous nos pays ont pris
un engagement envers les générations
futures envers les citoyens de limiter
la température de la terre
l'augmentation de la température de la
terre 1,5 ou 2 degrés et les
scientifiques nous ont dit que pour
arriver à cet objectif et bien l'horizon
2000 70 on ne pouvait plus émettre de
co2 issues de des ressources fossiles
sur 95
sur les 196 pays je vous laisse deviner
qui est celui qui n'a pas signé se sont
engagés maintenant il faut savoir
comment le faire alors la suisse qui
représente un millième du monde
on est huit millions d'habitants il ya 1
8 milliard dans le monde a décidé d'être
pionnière dans ce domaine la suisse
avait déjà une expérience dans
l'hydroélectricité dans les énergies
renouvelables dans le solaire
elle a donc décidé de devenir pionnière
elle a décidé de devenir indépendante et
neutre indépendante voulait dire qu'elle
n'est le plus acheté de ressources
énergétiques à l'extérieur de ses
frontières et neutre dans le sens où
elle n'allait plus émettre de co2
évidemment la population a de suite dit
oui mais nous on veut pas donner
plein d'argent et se ruiner pour ne pas
polluer
et puis d'autre part on ne peut pas
retourner vivre dans les cavernes
les ingénieurs ont donc dit ben il faut
regarder notre notre système énergétique
alors quand on regarde notre système
énergétique ça c'est la situation en
chaque petit carré en fait correspond
alors un seul quart et c'est la
consommation énergétique dont un homme a
besoin pour vivre
tous les autres c'est les consommations
énergétiques que l'on fait pour
satisfaire nos besoins
la moitié de notre dépense énergétique
c'est pour se loger pour vivre dans les
bâtiments 30% pour se déplacer et le
reste pour l'industrie alors on voit
déjà une problématique avec les bêtes
les bâtiments c'est que donc on dépense
plus d'énergie en hiver qu'en été
puisqu'on est dans un pays froid alors
comment est-ce qu'on va résoudre le
problème la première chose qu'on s'est
dit mais on va améliorer les bâtiments
il ya plein de gens qui amènent plein de
standards l'âme énergie etc
on s'est dit on sait très bien sauf que
il ya plein de bâtiments existants et
que même si on les rénova bien on va pas
arriver à vraiment réduire notre
consommation énergétique parce qu'en
même temps la population augmente et
puis les gens voudraient être plus
confortable ont besoin de plus de place
donc on s'est dit que ce n'est pas sur
la consommation énergétique que l'on va
pouvoir jouer
par contre sur la manière d'en fournir
les besoins de la manière de chauffeurs
bâtiment là on pouvait trouver une
solution les thermodyn initial nous ont
dit vous savez au lieu de brûler du gaz
naturel dans une chaudière
vous pourriez utiliser une pompe à
chaleur la différence entre les deux
c'est que théoriquement eh bien on a
besoin de dix fois moins d'énergie pour
chauffer un bâtiment avec une pompe à
chaleur que pour lorsqu'on utilise une
chaudière
donc la solution était la pompe à
chaleur la pompe à chaleur consiste à
les prendre de la chaleur dans
l'environnement et l'amener à l'endroit
où on en a besoin dans la ville qui est
quand même 80 % 2
où se trouve leur 80% la population ce
n'était pas aussi facile d'installer une
pompe à chaleur dans chacun des
bâtiments
lorsqu'on a dit c'est qu'on allait
diviser la pompe à chaleur en deux d'une
part une pompe à chaleur qui va aller
chercher l'énergie à l'endroit où elle
est la plus chaude dans un lac dans une
rivière dans le sol ou même dans
l'industrie qui avait de la chaleur en
trop et l'amener à l'endroit où on en a
besoin et pour ça on avait besoin d'un
fluide qui allait transférer l'énergie
depuis un endroit à un autre et les
suisses là ont proposé une nouvelle
technologie
une technologie qui n'allait pas
utiliser l'eau mais qu'ils allaient
utiliser le co2 alors le co2 il avait
une caractéristique c'est qu'à 17 degrés
ils pouvaient s'évaporer où se condenser
est délivrée beaucoup d'énergie par
cette opération de passer de l'état
liquide à l'état vapeur et donc on a
proposé d'utiliser un réseau co2 qui
allait être mis dans les trottoirs et
qui permettait en condensant la vapeur
et en produisant du liquide de chauffer
les bâtiments grâce à une pompe à
chaleur qui permettait aussi de
refroidir par en prenant le liquide et
enlève apport en tous les bâtiments qui
avait besoin d'être refroidit et c'était
pas si innocent que ça dans les
centres-villes il y avait souvent des
banques avec des serveurs qui devait
être refroidi il y avait des malades et
des supermarchés qui avaient des frigos
qui devait être refroidis et donc ça me
permettait d'aller récupérer la chaleur
dans tout ce qui devait être refroidi
pour chauffer tout ce qui devait être
chauffée évidemment il fallait faire la
balance et la balance on allait la faire
au bon endroit
et comme on a 28 ou qui transportait la
chaleur et mais on pouvait aller dans un
lac
on pouvait aller dans le sol pour se
récupérer cette chaleur un autre
avantage c'est que le co2 ne va pas gelé
donc au lieu de devoir creuser très
profond pour mettre des tuyaux d'eau eh
bien on pouvait proposer des trottoirs
qui était préfabriqué dans lequel il y
avait ces deux tuyaux qui alimentait
tout tout les tous les bâtiments puis le
fait que je dis un trottoir ça
intéressait pas mal les autorités parce
que celui qui mettait des trottoirs
préfabriqués il rénover la ville et puis
pouvait avoir une médaille à la fin de
son mandat donc ça c'était aussi notre
avantage
alors quand on a regardé quelle était la
conséquence
de ça on a remplacé un système qui
fonctionnait avec des chaudières par un
système qui fonctionnait avec ce système
de pompe à chaleur on a constaté qu'on
pouvait diviser notre facture
énergétique par un facteur 6 d'accord ça
veut dire que maintenant
au lieu de dépenser 100 je compte je
dépense plus que 18 il me restait à
fournir ces 18 et c18 je pouvais les
fournir comment c'était d'électricité
donc la réponse était assez simple nous
allons mettre sur tous les toits de la
ville des panneaux photovoltaïques
alors mettre un panneau photovoltaïque
audio au dessus d'un toit c'est facile
sauf que mettre un panneau
photovoltaïque qui fait fonctionner une
pompe à chaleur c'est à dire qu'ils
utilisent l'énergie solaire quand on en
a pas besoin
c'était plus compliqué et c'est là qu'on
a utilisé toute la technologie de
l'information et la gestion qui
pouvaient être réalisés on est allé on a
coordonné en fait la production
d'énergie solaire avec la consommation
de l'électricité produite de manière à
se délivrer tous les services et
l'intelligence artificielle nous
permettait de prédire à la fois quand il
y aurait des nuages et quand les
personnes étaient dans la maison pour
être chauffée et aussi quel est l état
du système et surtout des stocks et
grâce à ça on a pu fournir dans les dix
huit pour cent qui me restait à fournir
est bien là deux tiers pouvaient être
produits directement par l'énergie
solaire il me restait donc 6% à fournir
pour rendre la ville entièrement
autonome alors comment ce qu'on a fait
il y avait une technologie que qui était
développé à ce moment là qu'ils étaient
émergentes c'était pas une nouvelle
c'était pas une ancienne technologie
c'est une nouvelle technologie qui en
développement c'était la pile à
combustible
la pile à combustible permettait de
prendre du gaz de produire de
l'électricité avec un très bon rendement
bien meilleur que ce que les centrales
thermiques pouvait faire en plus elle
est assez petit donc on pouvait les
mettre dans les bâtiments et donc
récupérer la chaleur est une
caractéristique chimiques
supplémentaires c'est qu'elle permettait
de capturer le co2 donc ça veut dire
qu'en tout cas même si on utilisait du
gaz qui venait d'une ressource fossile
on aurait récupéré le co2 on n'aurait
pas mis dans l'atmosphère
on s'est dit ça c'est une très belle
technologie d'autant plus
qu'on peut utiliser tous nos déchets
organiques qu'on peut transformer en
biométhane donc à ce moment là même le
gaz qu'on allait utiliser était en gaz
vers une chose qu'on a constaté c'est
que en été on avait beaucoup trop de
soleil le fait de recevoir beaucoup de
soleil en été nous poser un problème
parce qu'on ne savait pas quoi faire de
l'électricité est là on l'a décidé
les suisses ont décidé de remplacer la
technologie qui était la technologie de
la pile à combustible d'inverser le
processus est de prendre du co2 de
prendre de l'eau de prendre l'énergie
solaire qui était en trop et grâce à un
processus chimique de faire du méthane
et le méthane on pouvait le stocker donc
on avait de l'énergie stockée
ce système avait une très bonne
efficacité en fait il faisait la même
chose que la photosynthèse mais comme il
était industrialisés il aller beaucoup
plus vite ils étaient beaucoup plus
efficace donc on était on allait prendre
le co2 qu'on aurait stocké en hiver et
on allait en tout deux transformés en
méthane et en hiver on allait prendre ce
méthane et grâce à la pile à combustible
un produit électricité dont on avait
besoin pour entraîner nos pompes à
chaleur pour s'éclairer et on allait
récupérer le co2 qu'on en est ok pour la
prochaine saison
en ce faisant on a finalement constaté
que la ville qui au départ utilisait
beaucoup d'énergie fossile pouvait être
entièrement alimentés par de l'énergie
renouvelable l'énergie qui se trouvaient
sur les toits mais entièrement c'est à
dire autant en été qu'en hiver et en
plus l'investissement n'était pas si
grand que ça et donc les gens se sont
dit mais comment ce qu'on fait pour
réaliser ça alors ils se sont mis
ensemble ensemble ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que les autorités ont dit mais
nous on doit développer une
infrastructure on a développé des
réseaux le réseau gaz réseau co2 le
réseau d'eau on va promouvoir cette
utilisation et on va aider à l'opération
du système se mettre ensemble voulait
dire aussi que on a réalisé que on ne
devait plus acheter du pétrole
d'accord donc ça veut dire que
maintenant tout le service énergétique
allaient être liés
à investir des équipements qui
collectent l'énergie solaire que l'on
reçoit sur les toits la conséquence
c'est qu'on avait on allait créer
beaucoup d'emplois nouveaux et que pour
crier ses nouveaux emplois il fallait
avoir des gens qui étaient formés donc
on a mis en place un système de
formation qui a éduqué qui a fait des
nouveaux métiers que les industriels se
sont empressés de saisir pour construire
de nouvelles usines pour développer la
technologie et même proposer de nouveaux
business models et puis alors on a dû
aller convaincre les banquiers par les
banquiers dépensait beaucoup de leur
argent pour soutenir l'industrie du
pétrole
mais leur leur argent s'était aussi nos
fonds de pension donc les citoyens ont
dit mais utiliser nos fonds de pension
pour créer des emplois chez nous et
arrêter de dépenser de l'argent sur une
énergie qui n'a plus aucun avenir
la preuve c'est qu'on peut être autonome
certains ont dit oui mais vous n'avez
résolu que la moitié du problème puisque
vous étiez dans la ville et qu'est ce
qui se passe avec l'industrie qu'est ce
qui se passe avec la mobilité alors on a
dit ok on va s'occuper de l'industrie au
l'industrie aujourd'hui à lutter à ce
moment-là il utilisait beaucoup de
pétrole pour faire les produits pour
nous alimenter pour alimenter nos villes
et les citoyens on s'est dit ben il faut
arriver à trouver une solution la
première chose qu'on a dit c'est
améliorer votre efficacité et puis on a
10 mai dans la ville on partage pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne partagerait pas aussi
dans l'industrie et on a constaté que
certains industriels certains procédés
pouvaient donner leur énergie à d'autres
procédés et puis aussi que certains
procédés produisait des déchets qui
pouvait devenir des matières premières
pour un autre procédé pour une autre
industrie
alors si vous voyez le schéma ici il est
déjà très similaire à ce qu'on voit à
monter par exemple pour les gens qui
sont valaisans les uns du ciel ont
commencé à partager l'énergie ont aussi
partagé des ressources partagées des
déchets évidemment quand on a entendu
déchets on s'est dit mais pourquoi ne
pas aussi intégrer la ville qui produit
des déchets et on a utilisé à ce moment
là un système qui était à la fois
l'industrie
à la fois la ville et le traitement de
ces déchets pour utiliser l'énergie de
l'industrie pour recycler utiliser
l'énergie de l'industrie pour utiliser
des matières premières des déchets et au
total on avait déjà un système qui
fonctionnait bien et c'est quand même
une question
la question s'était il l'industrie a
besoin d'énergie et la réponse qu'on a
apporté à ça c'est d'utiliser la
biomasse la biomasse était le bois qui
étaient produits par nos forêts qu on
utilisait principalement pour empêcher
nos forêts de de s'éroder et on a dit
mais pourquoi pas utiliser le bois et
quand on convertit le bois en carburant
eh bien on a de l'énergie qui est mise à
disposition sous forme de chaleur et on
a dit on va utiliser cette chaleur pour
alimenter l'industrie
on va utiliser le carbone qui est dans
le bois pour faire du plastique
donc on fait des bioproduits et au total
et bien qu'est-ce qu'on peut montrer
c'est que l'industrie devient
complètement intégré c'est ce qu'on
appelle la symbiose industriels elle est
complètement intégrée avec le système
ambiant et peut être mais alimentés avec
l'énergie renouvelable un autre élément
qui était intéressant c'est que malgré
tout l'industrie avec de l'énergie
résiduelle et puis je vous rappelle que
j'avais un réseau co2 qui me permettait
de prendre cette énergie dans
l'industrie et l'amener dans la ville
est donc maintenant les gens pourraient
être ceux chauffés par l'énergie
résiduelle de la ville et par leur
traitement de leurs déchets donc le
système était vraiment parfait il
restait à résoudre le problème du
transport alors de transport c'est 35 %
de notre consommation c'était 35 % de la
consommation énergétique mais il est
très vite apparu que si on développait
des véhicules à base d'électricité
on a l'air bien plus efficace alors un
véhicule électrique par définition est
plus efficace en plus quand ils freinent
il peut récupérer de l'énergie
et donc on a développé tout un système
de transport pas seulement les petites
voitures
on a aussi les camions les voitures qui
fonctionnent parce qu'elles ont des
besoins de plus grandes distances à
parcourir de plus grandes licences de
qui fonctionnent à l'hydrogène des
véhicules hybrides les véhicules
hybrides ils utilisent du carburant mais
c'est pas grave parce que mon carburant
je venais de le produire dans
l'industrie pour chauffer mon industrie
donc c'était très bien je l'avais à ma
disposition et quand on a fait
l'inventaire a dit ah non on a besoin
d'électricité
et puis je me suis rangé je peux vous
dire qu'on n'a pas parlé de deux types
des lectrices de ressources énergétiques
c'est l'hydraulique et l'éolien et on
les valises ont particulièrement
connaissait très bien
l'utilisation de l'énergie hydraulique
au total on a eu donc un système qui
était complètement intégrés qu'ils
fournissent et tous les besoins dont la
suisse avait besoin le confort dans les
bâtiments tous les produits dont les
personnes personnes désiraient même la
nourriture pourraient être produites de
manière intégrée car la partie qui ne
finissait pas dans notre assiette
pouvait être traité comme déchets et
être transformé en gaz pour nous
chauffer nous déplacer ou pour produire
et la mobilité était résoudre résolu
également alors on a un système
l'inquiéter entièrement autonome en
énergie
en plus c'est un système qui avait fait
appel à tous les éléments de la société
à la fois les décideurs qui nous ont
aidés à mettre en place l'infrastructure
qui ont mis en place le système
d'éducation qui ont permis d'avoir des
ouvriers et des industriels et des
ingénieurs et des architectes qui
permettait de concevoir le système et
qui ont même été capable de convaincre
les banquiers de nous aider à devenir
indépendant et neutre et en plus
exemplaires
[Applaudissements]